so how do we communicate the beauty and
power of mathematics a few years ago I
made a film called rights of love and
math with a wonderful French film
director Ren Grove I was in Paris doing
some mathematical work and suddenly I
felt inspired to make a film because I
find that sometimes you know we first of
all we don't do enough communicating
mathematics to people outside of the
subject we professional mathematicians
don't do enough and when we do that
sometimes we don't do it in the most
effective way often you know I know I
notice how people start yawning you know
30 seconds into a conversation when I
try to explain the form ode to them so
then I though I thought what it would do
something radically different what if
instead of trying to explain a formula
at a kind of a rigorous and cerebral
level what if we try to do it at a more
visceral and emotional intuitive level
so instead of trying to explain the
details what if we make a tattoo of a
mathematical formula and let the viewer
see see it in this very different
context in the context of a film which
is an allegory about a formula of love
so that's how the idea of the film
rights of love and math came about the
premise of the film is that a
mathematician after many years of hard
work find the formula of love and at
first he's elated he's so happy that he
found this formula which explains
everything and will make everyone happy
and then of course he realises the flip
side of the formula it could be used for
evil as well as for good and here of
course I'm alluding to misuse of
mathematical models in our world and the
possibility that the mathematical
formula can actually do harm so he
realizes that and he is scared he's
afraid he wants to protect the formula
and to protect the formula he decides to
tattoo it on the body of the woman he
loves so we create this mythical world
and it's mythical world she his lover
represents mathematics itself so the
film is really about his love affair
with mathematics and that's what we try
to convey and we try to show the formal
in the different light and we try to
show the passion which is involved in
doing mathematics which when he makes
the tattoo he completely shuts himself
out from the rest of the world it's just
him and the formula and nothing else
that's how we do math Michael research
it's it's really a struggle of ideas
it's an struggle with oneself trying to
understand things at the deeper level
it's a very emotional and passionate
process and we wanted to convey that in
our film and also of course the idea
that when you discover that formula it
really gets under your skin like the ink
of a tattoo so when we show the film
someone always asks but what what does
this formula mean and that's exactly
what we wanted we wanted to pick a
viewers curiosity to inspire them to ask
a question what is the meaning of the
formula in other words we wanted the
viewer to appreciate the beauty of the
formula just in an aesthetic sense but
not stop there but use it rather as a
portal to the understanding of the
intellectual beauty of the formula so
they asked put as a formal mean and
actually the formula we use in the film
is a formula for one of my papers which
might was two co-authors we try to
understand some deep questions in
quantum field theory and in the course
of our investigation we came up with
this unexpected surprising formula
that's the formula which is tattooed in
the film and the second question that
people like to ask is is there a formula
of love
there's a formula of love really exist
and the answer I like to give is that
actually every formula we discover is a
formula of love and that's because these
formulas are presenting deep and
fundamental about the world and perhaps
even more importantly every formula is
objective represents objective truth
which means the same thing to all of us
and therefore the each of those formulas
is this great connector which connects
me to anyone else in the world and
therefore it's something that
helps me to love the world and to love
everyone who lives in this world